nachgefragt in der Hauptstadt bei Robin
Alexander von der Welt grüß Sie ganz
herzlich guten Tag und hat Roms gemacht
in Thüringen und die Frage ist bringen
diese Verschwörungen gegen die AFD ich
bezeichne es mal so also das
zusammenrotten der Parteien um einen
afd-kandidaten zu verhindern wirklich
etwas in Deutschland
also ehrlich gesagt die Worte
Verschwörung und zusammenrotten die
würde ich mir noch mal überlegen weil
eine Stichwahl hat ja quasi naturgemäß
dass es zwei Kandidaten gibt und die die
rausgeflogen sind sagen ihren WLAN wer
ihn näher steht also da kann ich keine
Verschwörung erkennen lass mal die Worte
Wetten beenden warten also diese
gemeinsame Allianz in einer Stichwahl
ist ja schon bemerkenswert das können
wir auch an anderen Stellen das ist der
Allianzen gibt aber was sagt das über
uns in Deutschland über die Situation
über die Demokratie und die Wahlen und
die Ergebnisse aus
aber was hätte denn meinetwegen ein
sozial Demokrat in Sonnenberg tun sollen
hätte der sagen sollen ob jetzt CDU oder
AFD wählt das ist ganz egal also der der
Mann oder die Frau hat ja wahrscheinlich
ihren Landkreis im Herzen und hält das
für eine blöde Idee dass er von der AFD
regiert wird und sagt dann wählt halt
den anderen da kann ich überhaupt kein
Problem erkennen
das Problem werden wir erkennen wenn es
dann ans regieren geht und sich da
vielleicht
Dissonanzen auftun oder was auch immer
das können wir jetzt noch gar nicht
sagen
worauf ich eigentlich hin wollte ist wie
sieht das in der nähere Zukunft aus das
ist jetzt nur ein Landrat in einem
kleinen Kreis gewesen aber es stehen
danach andere Landratswahlen an und
demnächst jetzt zum Beispiel auch noch
Landtagswahlen womit rechnen Sie
bisher hatten wir in Landtagswahlen in
Ostdeutschland immer das Phänomen dass
der die Partei die in Führung war oder
die den Ministerpräsidenten stellte
Zulauf bekam weil die Mehrheit der Leute
auch in Ostdeutschland nämlich nicht
wollte dass die AFD bei ihnen auf den
ersten Platz kommt deshalb haben so
unterschiedliche politische Charaktere
die Michael Kretschmer in Sachsen oder
Bodo Ramelow in Thüringen von ganz
unterschiedlichen Parteien auch gewonnen
weil die Leute eben nicht wollten dass
die AFD den ersten Platz macht und ob
dieser Effekt weiter trägt im nächsten
Jahr wenn wieder ostdeutsche
Landtagswahlen sind das wird interessant
ja sieht ja in Thüringen beispielsweise
und in Sachsen nicht ganz so gut aus ist
dann tatsächlich der Bund dran schuld
das war es ja zum Beispiel der CDU
Generalsekretär sagt die Regierung in
Berlin die Themen die ja dort auch im
Wahlkampf bemüht worden von der AFD ähm
verfangen und bringen solche Ergebnisse
das eine Bundesregierung die so
schlechte Zustimmung hat in ganz
Deutschland und in Ostdeutschland ja
noch mal besonders und wenn sie ein
bisschen in spezielle ostdeutsche
Landschaften gehen nehmen wir mal die
Sächsische Schweiz oder nehmen wir
Gebiete in Thüringen oder Sachsen-Anhalt
da gibt es ja quasi keine ampelparteien
mehr und auch jetzt in Sonneberg worüber
wir sprechen war es ja die CDU die noch
ausreichend dagegen gehalten hat also
wenn man sich anguckt als ampelpartei
dass man in Teilen aus Deutschland gar
nicht mehr vorkommt dann finde ich liegt
die Überlegung woran das liegt dass man
da gar nicht mehr vorkommt nach
ja also kann man sagen das was er bemüht
wird als Argument der Bund ist Schuld
also die Bundesregierung ist schuld an
diesem Ergebnis würden sie das so
schützen
Schuldfragen würde ich prinzipiell eher
in der Kirche klären aber wenn sie jetzt
nach politischer Verantwortung Fragen
finde ich darf man die ruhig verteilen
klar ist dass die Ampel mit ihrer
Politik im Moment im Land schlecht
ankommt und Ostdeutschland besonders
schlecht darüber haben wir gesprochen
aber natürlich muss ich auch die
Opposition namentlich die Union einen
Kopf machen warum die Leute nicht sagen
wenn die die Ampel schlecht regiert
wählen war halt die CDU das war ja
früher immer so in Deutschland aber
drittens möchte ich auch nicht die Leute
aus ihrer Verantwortung entlassen weil
ähm wenn man eine Bundesregierung hat
die man nicht mag und vielleicht eine
Opposition die man nicht mag muss man
immer noch nicht AFD wählen sondern kann
sich etwas anderes überlegen mit diesem
weisen Satz setzt man am Punkt an diesem
Gespräch danke schön auch wenn Alexander
schauen wir mal in die Hauptstadt auch
wenn Alexander die Auswirkungen für uns
also gerade auch schon angesprochen was
heißt denn dieses Ereignis wo wir immer
noch nicht so richtig wissen was
wirklich genau passiert ist für uns in
Deutschland und in Europa und auch in
der westlichen Allianz
zum Beispiel hat das für die Bundeswehr
interessante Wirkungen die Bundeswehr
ist ja immer noch im afrikanischen Land
Mali präsent und ist dort in einen fast
schon Konflikt mit der Regierung geraten
die sie einmal eingeladen hat weil diese
Regierung in Mali sich eben auf jene
Wagner Truppen stützt die da jetzt am
Wochenende ein paar Stunden geputzt
haben und jetzt ist ja die Frage wenn
diese Wagner Leute in die russischen
regulären Verbände integriert werden
spielen Sie dann weiter diese Rolle in
Afrika und wenn sie das nicht tun was
heißt das für die Bundeswehr kann sie
dann länger dort bleiben oder im
Gegenteil muss sie vielleicht noch
schneller abgezogen werden das eine sehr
schwierige Frage die aber für viele
Bundeswehrsoldaten und ihre Familie ganz
wichtig ist ja nächste Frage ist dann
auch ähm wie stark ist war die mehr
Putin tatsächlich derzeit noch in
Anführungsstrichen noch kann man mit dem
eigentlich noch demnächst rechnen und
mit ihm verhandeln eventuell
der der Präsident der Russischen
Föderation bleibt immer der
Ansprechpartner für unsere Politiker und
es ist ja auch eine Legende dass das
nicht passieren würde also sowohl Angela
Merkel früher oder Olaf Scholz halten ja
Kontakt zu Putin und sprechen mit ihm
und das werden sie bestimmt auch weiter
tun die Frage ist natürlich wie stabil
Russland ist und das wiederum ist etwas
was auch Länder interessieren könnte die
bisher Russland gestützt haben und auch
den Krieg also wenn Sie sich zum
Beispiel anschauen China für die ja
Stabilität ein zentrales Thema in ihrer
Außenpolitik ist die haben am Samstag
als dieser Putsch lief geschwiegen und
erst am Sonntag als sozusagen klar war
was vorerst entschieden ist eine
Mitteilung gemacht also viele Länder
werden sich angucken was tut da was
passiert da in Russland was ist das
überhaupt für ein Land wie stabil ist
das alles und ich glaube das wird in
einem größeren außenpolitischen
Zusammenhang war das ein sehr schlechtes
Wochenende für Putin ja und er kann auch
nicht sagen der Westen hat das
provoziert das kam quasi aus seinen
eigenen Reihen aus seinen Gefolgsleuten
und der Westen ist damit mal außen vor
ja für uns unsere deutsche Debatte ist
vielleicht interessant wir haben ja oft
noch Menschen bei uns auch in den
Talkshows oder in Zeitungen die den
Eindruck erwecken Russland wäre so eine
Art wie es früher die sowjetunieren war
also schon eine Diktatur aber ein ein
stabiles Land in Wirklichkeit Ringen da
Menschen miteinander die noch nicht mal
nur Oligarchen sind sondern wirklich
Gewalt Unternehmer also dass das das
sind Menschen die ihr Geld damit
verdienen überall auf der Welt schwerste
Menschenrechtsverletzungen zu begehen
und die Ringen jetzt um Russland in
Russland um die Macht und das muss man
sich vor Augen führen was das für ein
Land geworden ist ja und wir müssen uns
vor Augen führen dass wir gar nicht
wissen wie es weitergeht aber wenn
Alexander ich danke ganz herzlich für
das Gespräch heute morgen danke nach
Berlin